events in Russia have called into
question Vladimir Putin's Authority
but as the conflict grinds on and
Ukraine vies for dominance it looks
possible this war may only have one true
winner China's leader Xi Jinping when
this war ends China will be in Prime
position to take advantage of a new
world order that is emerging so why
could China come out on top
here's the economist Beijing bureau
chief David rennies three key takeaways
foreign
position is that it is a peace-loving
giant and neutral in this war but it's a
pro-russian suso neutrality the big gap
between the west and China is that
across European capitals in Washington
and other allies we want Vladimir Putin
to pay a high price for his war of
aggression China wants Putin to pay no
price at all China doesn't care who ends
up in control of luhansko Donetsk but
China does see opportunities to use the
war in Ukraine to advance a few core
national interests it wants to divide
the West to split Europe from America
they want to delegitimize the NATO
defense Alliance and finally China wants
to delegitimize and demonize sanctions
imposed on Russia
China is coldly calculating that by
refusing to take sides it could at the
end of this war end up as the only
important friend of a weakened Russia
and as the indispensable security
guarantor and Rebuilder of a shattered
Ukraine
you could imagine that Xi Jinping is
embarrassed about being best friends
with a loser that's not good in China's
dog eat dog world of politics but
actually China coldly calculates there
are opportunities in a Russia that is
weakened and more dependent on China
just as long as it's not so weak that it
falls apart and spreads Chaos on China's
borders some Western governments were
really skeptical that China could be an
honest peace broker it was so clearly on
Russia's side but now because the leader
of Ukraine Vladimir zelenski says that
he wants China at the table you're now
seeing people at least willing to let
China explain what it thinks zelenski
knows that Ukraine will only be safe if
there are serious security guarantees
that Russia won't just try this again
and the Reconstruction of Ukraine is
going to involve an extraordinary amount
of money and construction companies and
China is good at both of those
[Music]
Russia has burned its bridges with
European neighbors customers for its
energy in ways that are not going to be
fixed for a long time that leaves Russia
looking East and realizing that for all
its fears of arising China it doesn't
have a lot of alternatives
when China looks at the globe to look at
areas where it could Advance its
interests because it is so much more
dominant over Russia look at places like
the Arctic where Russia has actually
been quite wary of letting China take
advantage of melting sea ice creating
new shipping lanes new opportunities to
build ports as climate change unlocks
the Arctic but maybe Russia won't be in
the same position to say no when China
comes knocking this war in one corner of
Europe is reshaping the map of the world
order look at India a country that buys
most of its Advanced weapons from Russia
but has serious border disputes with its
neighbor China now India is more
receptive than it has ever sanded to
defense Partnerships with America why
because if you had a future conflict
between India and China the fear in
Delhi is that an all-powerful China
might pick up the phone to Moscow and
say don't send more weapons to India
China is patiently waiting for us to get
tired of this war and then they think a
colder more brutal World Order will
emerge in which might does make right
and Russia doesn't pay a high price for
its aggression and we learn to
accommodate great powers and that is a
world order that could suit China very
well
I'm David Rennie Beijing bureau chief
for more of our China coverage you can
click the link
thank you for watching and don't forget
to subscribe